>>> THE BIG GAME IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER, AND WING PIT HAS
YOUR PARTY COVERED.
>> WINGS ARE HERE!
>> WE'VE GOT GAME DAY SPECIALS
THAT WILL KEEP THE WHOLE PARTY
HAPPY, LIKE OUR TOUCHDOWN TRAY.
>> TWO DOZEN WINGS AND TWO
SAUCES FOR ONLY 24.99.
>> THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN BOTH
AGREE ON.
>> OR CALL
AN AUDIBLE.
AND TRY THE STREAM PLATTER.
>> JUICY BUFFALO WINGS FOR ONLY
39.99.
>> NOW WE'RE TALKING.
>> AND IF YOUR PARTY IS REALLY
RAGING, GO FOR TWO WITH WING PIT
TAILGATE FEAST.
>> 20 DOZEN WINGS, FIVE
ETHNICALLY TROUBLING SAUCES AND
A GALLON OF RANCH FOR JUST
89.99.
>> THANK YOU.
WE'RE PROBABLY GOOD ON WINGS,
THOUGH.
>> BUT YOU COULD BE GREAT ON
WINGS.
WITH WING PITS NEW TRAY OF
TEARS.
>> 600 OF OUR SUCCULENT WINGS
PLUS 16 BUTT-DESTROYING SAUCES
AND A KEG FULL OF RANCH
FOR ONLY 205.99.
>> WE DON'T NEED ALL THAT.
>> BUT YOU WANT IT JUST LIKE YOU
WANT WING PIT'S THE CHICKEN
SMOOTHIE.
IT'S 40 LIQUEFIED WINGS MIXED
WITH 80 PROOF ALCOHOL.
MUST BE OVER 12 TO ORDER.
>> OVER 12?
>> AND IF YOU'RE THIRSTY FOR
MORE, TRY THE CARNAGE PLATTER.
>> 3,000 WINGS
PACKED IN A BLACK CONTRACTOR BAG
THROWN STRAIGHT THROUGH YOUR
WINDOW IN TIME FOR KICKOFF.
>> HEY, IF YOU DON'T STOP, I'M
CALLING THE POLICE.
>> WELL, GOOD LUCK BECAUSE WE
OWN THE POLICE.
WING PIT DONATES MILLIONS TO
POLICE CHARITIES SO WE CAN
OPERATE WITH TOTAL IMMUNITY.
>> AND THAT LETS US SERVE YOU
THE CHICK NOBLE.
>> 5,000 WINGS, 10,000 BEANS, A
FULL GALLON OF HOT SAUCE
AIR-DROPPED RANCH.
>> ALL PUMPED INTO YOUR PARTY
VIA CEMENT SHOOT.
>> OH!
>> AHH!
>> WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
>> TO HONOR THE CHICKEN GOD OF
DEATH.
>> NO, PLEASE MAKE IT STOP.
>> YOUR FATE IS SEALED.
>> WING PIT.
LET THE SLAUGHTER BEGIN.